And I think this does conclude our special called BFA Committee meeting.
So. Thank you, Controller. We will now begin our Controller's Office
Budget Workshop. So, Controller, I believe at this time we're going to invite
your Deputy Director, Leonard Polk, up for his
presentation and give him a moment to get settled.
And thank you again, Controller, for your words of
wisdom.
Okay.
And I think our presentation is all queued up and
essentially ready to go, so we're a little ahead of schedule,
but we're doing great. So go ahead. You don't want to take
a 20 minutes? No, we're going to get right into it. We're going to get
right into it. I used to be in that chair. I remember how important it
is to move people through. Yes, sir. Thank you.
Okay. On behalf of the 53
almost employees working tirelessly to protect our City's fiscal health,
I'm pleased to present the proposed FY 23 budget
for the Office of the City Controller. As mentioned, Deputy Director Leonard
Polk is here to assist me in answering some of the
more detailed questions, but we'll go ahead and get
into the presentation. First and foremost, the mission of the Controller's
Office is project the financial integrity of Houston's municipal government.
To accomplish this, the Office is responsible for managing all payroll
and vendor payments, conducting audits,
managing a $5 billion investment portfolio and a $14
billion debt portfolio, which we do in house, preparing accurate
and timely financial statements, providing fiscal leadership
on policy issues relating to the City's financial health.
We are the independent authority to conduct performance reviews and
audits of the City's Departments, and we assess the City and region's
future financial outlook with accurate forecasts of projected revenues and
expenses, among other indicators. As we'll discuss
today, the proposed budget for FY 23 totals $8,954,843,
and that represents
an increase of 2.5% from the fiscal year 22
budgeted amount of $8,730,277.
So this increase represents a net change of $224,566,
and that's primarily
attributable to rising amounts in restricted accounts.
So the increase in pension contributions,
contractual pay raises for municipal employees as well.
Of the total proposed operating budget,
84%, or $7,548,436
of expenses, are associated with personnel costs.
So, similar to the overall City, the Office
of City Controller does not have revenue to report, and there is
no change in the FTE count from FY 22 to FY 23.
So looking at if we can go back sorry, one slide and
the chart. Looking at
our organizational chart, the Controller's Office. We have six divisions
that help protect the fiscal well being of the City, its enterprises, and its
component units. Our Operations Division is the workhorse
of the six and responsible for making sure City employees and vendors
get paid. Our Treasury Division is responsible for
managing a 5 billion investment portfolio and a $14 billion
debt portfolio. Again, both of those are done in house without outside managers.
And our Audit Division is responsible for the audit functions of
the City, including managing fraud, waste and abuse hotline.
In total, the FY 23 proposed budget of 8.9
million helps the nearly 53 Controller
Office team members across six divisions accomplish these key
tasks. Next slide.
To highlight the roles and responsibility of the Controller's Office,
we provide financial oversight of city operations.
We develop financial reports such as the Monthly Financial Report
and the annual Comprehensive Financial Report, the annual audit,
and perhaps most importantly, we process payments
to vendors and employees. And as defined in the
City Charter, the Controller's Office is responsible for certifying
the availability of funds for council action and the
audit functions of the City and its reporting units. Next slide.
So, as we mentioned previously, we don't have any revenue to report.
So we'll go to the next slide, and again no
revenue report. So we'll move on to slide six.
So the total proposed budget of 8.9 million is 2.5%
higher than the FY 22 budgeted amount.
The FY 21 actual is 7,813,000
946,000. And you can see the FY 22
budgeted is $8,730,277.
So the variance on those is 224,566,
again, previously mentioned 2.57%.
So we've seen a decrease in funding available for the audit
function and that is something that I know we've discussed around this
council table.
Between the term or retirement pay and competitive
edge among audit practitioners when compared to the
private sector, our audit division is doing more with
less. And we'll move on
to the next slide.
We can see the total proposed operating budget.
84%, or seven and a half million of expenses, are associated
with personnel costs. And of the remaining 16%,
1.4 million, a majority of expenses,
1.3 million. Of that 96% are associated with other services
and charges. Next slide.
In looking@the.net change to the FY 22
current budget, the FY 23 proposed budget includes an increase
of $51,970 as a result of service chargeback
accounts for items such as fuel, electricity. It counts.
It accounts an increase of 139,209
as a result of municipal pay increases through the Hope contract,
and a decrease of $9,090
due mainly to health benefit adjustments.
So we're projecting a decrease of 4000 in auditing services.
We have an increase of 20,000 for miscellaneous
support services, a decrease of 20,000 for information
resource services, and a decrease of 5000 for miscellaneous
other services. Next slide.
We see a major decrease in health insurance for active civilian
personnel and that would be a reduction of $42,506.
And we saw
the increase of 134,141 seen
in the FY 23 Hope salary adjustment. And that's attributable
to the contractually obligated pay increases that were
negotiated earlier this year.
Next slide.
So, in summary, expenditure increases are attributable to
rising amounts and restricted accounts. So it's really not anything that we're
adding. It's all nondiscretionary.
Those are increased pension contributions, contractually obligated,
municipal employee pay increases. We've really tried
to manage our budget very efficiently. I think we
and Leonard sometimes gets frustrated with me, but we always
go under budget. We're trying to be a good taxpayer
steward. But I would say, in closing,
if you look at the comparable amount of auditors to other Texas
cities, namely Dallas, San Antonio, Austin, we're well below
the number of auditors. And again, we talked about in the previous presentation
about making investments to kind of save recurring
money in the future. We've been and historically
shown that we can find and utilize savings
for the city through our audit division. So I would say
some of the unmet needs I know people have asked
about, that we really need more auditors.
So we'll move on to the next slide that's questions.
Thank you very much, Controller. I believe that covers
quite a bit here and we've got a couple of council members in the queue.
We'll start with Council member Sally Alcorn. Thank you,
Chair. You don't have any revenues,
but you make a lot of money for the city and treasury and investments.
Can you talk about that? About what, like rate of returns
for the past year?
Yes, overall, we have seen interest rates
rising. It's been, quite frankly, a little bit of a challenge
in our investment fund. When you look at the yield curve and
as rates rise, that yield curve tends to slope up positively.
You have a principle of duration and that's the time that your investment
is locked in. It's been a little bit of a dance
to try and get that duration perfectly
matched to beat the benchmark. We continue to think that rates are
going to continue to rise, so we don't want to lock in something at
3% and rates go to 4% because then we leave money on the table.
Equally complicating is the increase in
rates on our debt portfolio, because the opportunities to refinance are
now getting less opportune.
Luckily, again, my background in investment banking, eight years
working for an investment bank that primarily did fixed income,
I knew that this low interest rate environment was going to be a huge opportunity
for the city of Houston. We have to
date received over $600 million
in interest rate savings from refinancing the
city's debt. We've been very aggressive with this.
Other cities have been successful.
I think Houston is maybe one of the most successful. We are one of the
largest cities, so that number is quite high. But those
opportunities are probably going to be less
opportune going forward. But it's great that we did this,
because when you look at that and that's city wide,
but on average, a period of around 15 years
of a weighted average. So this is $30
million, $40 million a year that the
city is not paying in debt service. So that's savings. We'll continue to
identify those and be aggressive. It's just in this particular environment
and it all goes up and down. Eventually, maybe the rates will come back
down. We'll have more opportunity. Thanks. Thank you, council member.
And thank you, Controller. Next we'll hear from council member Amy
Peck. Thank you. And thank you, Controller.
Related to the reduction in your audit division.
As you know, I want to see more audits in the city and not fewer.
So can you talk a little bit about what that reduction will mean in terms
of how many fewer audits or what you're
able to do less with the reduction?
Yeah. So we'll use council office as
an example. Those of you all council members have seen through
these tough times with COVID and other reductions
in overall expenditures,
especially with costs like health care and pension and
all these other things rising. Unfortunately, we have
not been able to invest as much as we'd like to in the audit division.
We would love an example of a great
opportunity, if there was a way to find some of this federal money, to go
out and hire more auditors.
I was looking in my notes.
Houston has about ten. We have ten auditors or
ten total staff in our audit division. Austin has 28,
Dallas has 20, san Antonio has 23.
And so per employee,
houston has one auditor per 2122
employees, austin has one per 550. Dallas has
one per 700, and San Antonio has one per 500.
So they're a lot more in line. So just
to wrap up, if someone wanted to and I've made this plea before if someone
wanted to offer a budget amendment to fund more
auditors using some of the fungible ARPA money, I think
that would be a worthwhile investment. And I can tell you that if you look
at the amount of savings versus the audit budget,
it's a great return on investment. We spend a million and a half dollars a
year in audit, but during the time I've
been in office, I think now over 11 million in savings.
So, again, I think it's a good investment, and I
think with a bigger team, we could take on bigger audits and be more
effective in finding efficiencies for the city.
Thank you, Controller. That amendment is already on my list. All right, thank you.
Thank you. Wish come true. We got a follow up question from Council
Member Alcord. Thank you. It's my understanding we're not to submit budget amendments
for ARPA money, but not to say that that won't happen.
And then I was going to ask you about the paper reduction.
I am a firm believer that the city still uses citywide
entirely too much paper. And can you talk about what you're
doing with the invoices and how you really are trying to go paperless in
the Controller's office? Yeah, great question.
We've been working on this for some time.
Curiously, Harvey actually pushed our hand on a lot of these things.
We've moved to DocuSign to digitally sign a lot of
contracts, so that eliminates the movement of paper
in the Controller's office. We have moved to eliminate paper checks
and reduce invoices. There's still some work to do to
get truly paperless invoices. And just like with the DocuSign,
when we went through that process, we had five different departments
that wanted to use each their own system. And in
order to properly memorialize those signatures,
everyone needs to be on the same system. We were able to essentially get everyone
to have buy in. We'll need a little bit more buy in from all the
departments to get truly paperless invoicing. But I
would say that that is the future. I think even
around the council table and us still signing
a lot of these contracts that are paper, I know Leonard
helps in every week going through with our team
to sign off on all these contracts, but they're paper contracts that are being physically
moved. And I would say that that's something that could be a huge savings
for the administration to move to a truly paperless system.
It's difficult to transition, but a lot of the other cities and
smaller cities in this region, sugar Land, Paralym, Woodlands are
using Or, Sugar Land and Pearland are using these types of systems.
So something I think is a great idea. Thank you very much. And thank
you, I think actually for the TTI committee, we've heard from
the Houston Information Technology System about such technology being embraced
and hopefully soon incorporated. So again, Controller, thank you for
your remarks. I believe that's the end of our questions from council
and staff. And with that we will move. I just
wanted to take a point of personal privilege, please. I do have some staff
members. If you'd recognize your team, that'd be great. You guys are always welcome.
And I know we are in constant communication with many of
you, but I wanted to recognize our Chief Deputy City Controller,
Shannon Nobles, our Chief Operating Officer,
and Deputy Controller Alex Obergon. Vernon Lewis
is our Treasury Analyst, john Seideler is our Communications
Director, and Sharice Mosely, who heads our Treasury Division. I want
to just thank them and Leonard, as you all know,
this is a lot of work and we a lot of times get up here
and talk and look good, but it's these people that get us ready to
be able to do the things that we do. So thank them and thank you
all for your time today. Thank you, Controller. We know you have a great team
and we appreciate all the work you all do upstairs.
Thank you again. We've got two public speakers,
both of whom we believe are online virtually and
prepared with a question. And we'll start with Ms. Saba Blanding.
Good morning. Good to ask you all some more
questions today. Good morning.
My question is, and this is, I believe, directly to
council members, if you could add one to 2
million to the current budget, if that
magically appeared, what department and or service would you fund and why?
Well, I appreciate that question and we'll
commit it to the record. Ms. Blanding, thank you for that. I don't see
any council members jumping to respond,
but it is an interesting question, and we will consider
what we would do with an extra million or $2.
Thank you for that. Appreciate you being here today.
Thanks. And next, we'll hear from Mr.
Jason Oliver. Mr. Oliver, if you're with
us on mute. Yes, I'm here. There you are.
Go ahead, sir. So my first
question is to the controller. Thank you for the presentation.
Where are we in terms of the Checkbook program
implementation? Is the data and information
prepared? Some of us, if that information
is available, some of us in the public would be interested in working
on a version of it, depending on the city's timeline. So we're trying to get
an estimated time of completion for that. And then the
second question is to
Council Member Robinson. You had mentioned that policy budget amendments will be
out of order. I'm trying to figure out why the restriction
on budget amendments this year.
We're going to start with your first question, Mr. Oliver. Let's see if the
controller has something to respond. So the now
Open Finance, what we previously dubbed the Checkbook,
that program that we started was started and halted
and then restarted about a year
later. From the most recent report I've seen, there's about 40%
of the project that's been complete. I think the deadline
is September, October of this year.
But we would like to see that project completed and done
because I think, again, there'll be a lot of opportunity to
scrutinize expenditures and maybe find some more efficiencies. If not
only the Controller's office but council and every
citizen of Houston has the access to see in real time every expenditure,
not just vendor payments, but payroll and other expenditures.
So we've been cautiously optimistic
that this project will get online. I would just add the
genesis of this whole exercise was a
joint effort between the mayor's office and the Controller's office to
utilize and be eligible for a transparency star,
which is the State of Texas financial transparency ranking
system. And you get stars for different accomplishments.
Namely, the first one has to be putting all of your
expenses online. We're the only major city in the country that
doesn't have our payments online. But unfortunately,
we will not be eligible even if we do the Open Finance project
for that transparency star. We'll continue to be the only
major city in the country without the transparency
star, in the sense that if you don't have five years of historical
data, you don't qualify for the star. So I don't believe that
the Open Finance has agreed to be able to put that historical information.
It's something that we included in our project.
So I would say I'm hopeful that the project
will go online. I think it's going to be a great tool for not only
council and staff, but also for citizens of Houston.
And as a taxpayer, I want to be able to have this tool
available to me, but we also need to push to put that historical
data on there so that we are eligible to get that first
transparency star, because the other stars we're already doing.
We're already doing all the transparency stuff around the debt, the investments,
but we cannot get those stars until you get your first star, which is the
transparency portal and putting that five years of historical data on
there. So I would encourage this body, to encourage the administration
as a part of that project, to do the five years of historical data so
that we can in fact get we would probably get three or four stars right
off the bat. Thank you, Controller. And I do believe we're hearing
regular progress being made towards that goal. So hopefully, Mr.
Oliver, that addresses your first question. And as to your second
point about the words I read at the beginning of the meeting,
that coming from the administration is not a new restriction,
but really the mayor focusing on amendments
and trying to get ahead of those this year by reminding council
members in our offices that policy amendments are not appropriate
and will not be considered and
to focus on the budget. So appreciating your comments.
I want to thank you for being here again and I believe that
brings us to the conclusion of the public speaking component of your presentation.
Control Are. Thank you very much for being here and your
whole team and thank you
so much. We'll take a short break before our
next presentation from the mayor's office. And with
that, we'll take a brief adjournment.